good morning and welcome to the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences it's
wonderful to see so many here for this
press conference the Academy has
concluded its meeting and we are ready
to announce this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics and as usual I will read the
announcement first in Swedish then in
English then the citation in German
French and Russian I am Joran Hansen I'm
the secretary-general of the Academy and
with me here on podium is to my right
professor olga bottner the chairman of
the Nobel Committee for physics and on
my left side
professor Matt Larsen who is a member of
the committee and an expert in the field
of this year's prize
later on we hope that one of our new
nobel laureates with us on the line this
year's prize is about tools made from
light buddhist priests handler invective
of jews congregations cops academy or
adobe suite at attila sugar and roarton
or noble please if you seek for bond
written the good feeling are in Nam law
sir physique Mina helped until Arthur
Ashkan for an optical in certain order
steel and info below iske system Oh
maiden and Ralston remains until her
armor ooh Ock Donna Strickland for their
asthma tooth at Ultra Hinton Siva ultra
kurta of this couple sir
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has today decided to award the 2018
Nobel Prize in Physics with 1/2 to
author asking for the optical tweezers
and their application biological systems
and the other half jointly to
our muru and Donna Strickland for their
method of generating high intensity
ultra short optical pulses so whinin
helped an author Ashkan through the
optician in sector until on vandegraaff
the luggage is system consumed and when
health demands a man sure our Muru Donna
Strickland
filling the metro-detroit so you can
walk in tents either ultra codes or
optical pulses for materia or trash Caen
bulletins optics on aplicación system
via logic Apollo tamati a cogent more
Cheryl Mugu a Donna Strickland pool of
metal the generations and Pearson optic
intense ultra cold
Auto Raskin now each escape in 38 premia
Vitiello
each SC systemic share our Meru Donna
Strickland seismitoad can ROTC Visoko
intensiveness ultra karate hope teaches
get impulsive and you can see now our
new Nobel laureates with us on the
screen
Bambi author Ashkan was born in 1922 in
New York City he made his remarkable
invention at Bell Laboratories in New
Jersey in the United States
Cheryl Mugu was born in 1944 in
Albertville in France and he is
currently at the Ecole Polytechnique in
Palace so in France and also affiliated
with the University of Michigan in the
United States
Donna Strickland was born in 1959 in
golf Ontario Canada and she's currently
at the University of Waterloo in Canada
dr. Moreau and Strickland did much of
the groundbreaking work together at the
University of Rochester in the United
States now I would like to ask the
chairman of the Nobel Committee
professor Bortner to make some remarks
about this year's Nobel Prize thank you
over the past six DK
it's lasers and laser based devices have
become indispensable in many different
areas of society with its long range
narrow beam that can be focused on a
tiny spot a laser provides high power
over a small area useful for cutting
drilling welding and micro machining
other applications are bond billions of
people make daily use of optical disk
drives
laser printers and barcode scanners or
are entertained by amazing laser light
shows millions undergo laser surgery or
a laser skin treatment the laser is
truly one of the many examples of how a
so called blue sky discovery in
fundamental science eventually may
transform our daily lives
today we celebrate two inventions within
the field of laser physics that have
opened new scientific vistas but what's
more have already led to applications of
direct benefit to society optical
tweezers allowing control of tiny living
organisms and an amplification technique
enabling construction of high-intensity
compact laser systems and with that I
hand over to my colleague professor
Larson we'll give you more details yes
please
so author Ashkan invented the optical
tweezers and he did this in three steps
if you look at the upper panel he
realized that he could using the
radiation pressure from a laser and push
a small micro sized transparent sphere
in the direction of the laser beam he
also realized the middle panel that
because the laser beam is not
homogeneous it's more intense in the
center the sphere will be pushed into
the center by so-called gradient
gradient forces and finally he took a
lens and focused the beam so that he
could trap he could keep the small
sphere fixed in space and we will now
make a small demonstration of this using
a hairdryer and a ping-pong ball and it
will be my colleague in the committee
under Arabic who will do this
demonstration and please note now that
he can tint the hairdryer and still keep
the ping-pong ball under control this is
a simple test you can do yourself at
home if you want so of course it wasn't
the fact that he could trap a small
sphere that was the real breakthrough
the real breakthrough came when author
ashram demonstrated that he could trap
in the tweezer that he could trap
viruses bacteria and even living cells
and this led to an a very interesting
development very important development
in here we will demonstrate what happens
if we take molecular motors this is a
molecule that is doing work in the cell
in this case it's a Kennison it's a
protein and it's attached to a sphere
which is now in the optical tweezers and
the molecular motor will now start to
walk on a cellular cell skeleton but
feeling the resistance from the from the
sphere it's like gladiator contestant
strapped with an elastic band and you
walk and it becomes more
more heavy to walk because the force is
pushing you back by doing this
experiment it was possible to measure
the force between the cell skeleton and
the keynesian molecule and it was also
possible to measure the step size now we
come to the second part of this year's
Nobel Prize to get our Moreau and Donna
Strickland and what you see here is the
development of pulse laser pulse
intensity as a function of time from the
very beginning when the first laser was
constructed in 1960 by my mom and up to
1985 and what you see there is a first
rather sharp increase in pulse intensity
but then it levels off and this became a
problem because the technology of that
time was not scalable it was not
possible to go to higher intensity
because of the amplifier damage and the
way to come over this hurdle was the
invention of the chart pulse
amplification by Maureen Strickland and
this was really the core of Donna
sleekness PhD thesis so the idea and
what they demonstrated is the following
you take a short pulse you stretch it in
time maybe a factor of thousand and then
the amplitude of the pulse will decrease
also a factor of thousand then you take
the pulse and send it through the
amplifier the pulse is increased in
amplitude and finally in the finals that
you compress the pulse so that it has
the same duration as your importance but
now with a much higher intensity and
here you can see the development of
policy intensity after the invention of
the CPI technique basically every four
or five years the pulse intensity
doubled and this gave a possibility for
a rather wide range of applications both
in basic science and in more practical
applications and here you see how high
intensity ultrashort pulses they are
between 10 200 femtoseconds one fan per
second is a million of the billions of a
second
in the upper panel you see very high
intensity pulses coming roughly one per
second like this and these pulses can be
used for laser particle acceleration you
want to accelerate electrons or protons
and this is now a development that we
can already see could be of importance
for cancer therapy in the future in the
middle panel you see pulse is coming
roughly 1000 per second the intensity is
a little bit lower and these pulses are
adopted to a new field of science called
up to second science and up to seconds
is even much shorter than a femtosecond
one thousandth of a femtosecond
and by using these auto second pulses
you can explore how electrons are moving
in atoms and molecules very short time
scale in the lower panel the frequency
has increased even more than are now 100
thousand policies per second but the
intensity is a little bit lower and
these policies are extremely useful for
high precision measurement high
precision interaction with with with
matter and I'll give you one example how
they can be used and this is now CPI
femtosecond laser that is used to
correct myopia or nearsightedness and
then the femtosecond laser is in the
cornea creating a small down straight
piece of tissue which is called a
lenticular
the femtosecond laser is also used to
make a small incision in the cornea so
that the lenticular can be extracted
with with a small instrument and by
doing this you are decreasing the the
refractive power of the eye so that your
focus is now on the retina and not a
little bit before the retina and the
nearsightedness I can show you this is
something I'm very well familiar with
and so finally we are today awarding the
Nobel Prize for groundbreaking
inventions in the field of laser physics
to author a skin
we are armored oh and Donna Strickland
thank you thank you much we may now have
one of our new nobel laureates with us
on the phone dr. Strickland are you
there hello this is John Hanson again
I'm the guy who gave you the good news
what is it 45 minutes ago or so okay and
right now we're having a press
conference here at the Royal Academy of
Sciences large number of journalists and
I'm sure they would like to ask you some
questions are you ready okay I got too
much Sun hating it from Swedish
television
okay excuse me can you hear him no I'm
sorry I cannot there was something wrong
sorry about that we lacked a microphone
here
congratulations I was curious about how
you found this as in the short
introduction it was described as a blue
sky discovery and was it and how okay so
I don't know if you also have sure art
on the phone too but I was a PhD student
at the time keep that in mind I think a
lot of things always is going on pulse
compression was already going on
different people were trying to get
short pulses amplified in different ways
but I think that it's somewhat I guess
it's thinking outside the box to stretch
first and then amplify most people were
amplifying and trying to list to impress
whatever they had amplified so I don't
know if that answers the question hmm
thank you more questions the lady over
there you get the microphone thank you
I'm anali making her arm from Swedish TV
for congratulation on the prize thank
you you are the third woman ever getting
the Nobel Prize in Physics okay I
thought there might have been more but I
couldn't think well obviously we need to
celebrate Oh women physicists because
we're out there and hopefully in time
it'll start coming forward at a faster
rate maybe I don't know what to say I'm
honored to be one of those women yeah
yes there's gentleman over there The
Associated Press first of all
congratulations and sickle how did you
react when you receive the phone call
this
morning what was your first thought
Center and your thoughts on sharing this
price with these other with these other
lawyers well first of all you have to
think it's crazy so that was my first
thought and you do always wonder if it's
real
as far as shared it was Gerard of course
he was my supervisor and mentor and he
has taken CPA to great heights so he
definitely deserves this award and I so
happy that aren't asking also one I
think that you know he made so many
discoveries early on that other people
have done great things with it it's
fantastic that he is finally recognized
thank you yes I am is not proved from
their daily doggins new yet there in
terms of it's a newspaper it's a
newspaper based in Stockholm and in
terms of practical applications that
make some difference in people's lives
what are your favorites from your own
research I'm afraid I haven't done
anything that was practical for for
somebody I think the main practical
application of CPA so far has been in
the eye surgery it was the first one and
I think it is the one that is used by
the most people for something practical
and it was already discussed in the
press conference but no I think it's
it's still being used mostly by
shouldn't moc but I think the push
towards higher intensities and shorter
pulses and things will lead to even more
it's already being used for machining as
well I should I should say that it does
machine things like glass just like a
machine see I thank you are there more
questions to our Nuria to dr. Strickland
yes lady over there
congratulations
I'm sufficient access song from green
post and channel radio I just like to
follow up for this question the previous
question so in which feel do you think
your invention
be used can you elaborate a little bit
thank you in which field ya that you
expect further applications of the
technology well I mean I think I think
at this point it's it's just used almost
ubiquitously in so many different ways
it is using laser machining it's the
hope is that it will work you know very
large lasers are being built around the
world right now some of them are hoping
to do laser acceleration some of them
are hoping to you know cure cancer you
know it seems to be just about
everywhere high intensity lasers just
because of the way it interacts with the
medium is different and but it would be
in chemistry engineering so this
development has just started and we can
expect much more to come that's exciting
news thank you very much for being with
us dr. Strickland and we look forward to
seeing you here in Stockholm in December
great thank you bye bye for now that's
high now are there questions to the
panel I know you're eager to have your
individual interviews but maybe some of
you would like to ask something while
we're all here no
please did you talk to all of this
nearest Lawrence yes we did there was a
bit of a problem with one of the phone
connections and that's why we were
delayed for five minutes but we spoken
to all of them and doctor Ashkan told us
that he may not be able to give any
interviews because he's very busy with
his latest scientific paper more
questions
one more over there gentlemen from
Associated Press I think you for the
question so this year we see a female
laureate winner as was pointed out the
third only in physics and we spoke in
the last few years about female
representation within this prize I
understand that you cannot talk about
people that have been nominated per se
but would you be able to give us an idea
of the percentage of women that are
nominated for these prizes we have not I
don't have the statistics here in front
of me it's it's a small percentage
that's for sure and that's why we're
taking measures to encourage more
nominations because we don't want to
miss anyone let me point out that these
measures that we have been mentioning in
the last few days or is a lot part of a
long process and has actually had no
effect for this year's prize and it's
important to remember that the Nobel
Prize is awarded for discoveries and
inventions and those who receive it have
made major contributions to humankind
and that's why they get the prize please
I mean I can I we cannot give you the
percentages of course but let me just
point out that the percentage reflects
the number of women in science back if
you go back to
thirty years so the number has been
increasing steadily over the years but
the number of nominations rather reflect
the percentages as they were saying two
or three decades back in time thank you
good point if there are no more
questions thank you very much now the
individual interviews but we close this
press conference thank you and welcome
back tomorrow for chemistry
okay
yes that would be your betters work
remember
that's lotion member of the Nobel
Committee for physics inventions were
awarded today it was about the tools
made of life sounds actually like
science fiction can you say something of
the history behind the optical tweezers
for example I think that author Ashkan
very soon after the first laser had been
constructed realized that suddenly there
was available a tool of light or the
totally different quality than you had
earlier and he started to think about
how can one use his tool to manipulate
objects and he realized that by thinking
about this he realized that just take a
small micro sized transparent sphere it
should be possible even if the radiation
pressure from the laser is very small it
should be possible to manipulate such a
sphere and indeed he was correct and
already 1970 he had demonstrated this so
that but and of course that was a long
development one development that that
went into the direction of manipulating
atoms something much smaller than than
microsites feared but he also wanted to
think about something much more complex
than a sphere namely
viruses bacteria even living cells
hiko trap so that and that was of course
the real breakthrough that one could
manipulate as such very complex objects
same time you can say that the dream of
using radiation pressure for example
like solar arrays is very much if you go
a long time back come in already clipped
Kepler realized that radiation pressure
from the Sun could explain how the comet
tails are behaving when they are coming
in and out in the neighborhood of the
Sun so indeed it is you know it is an
older subject but it was really the
invention of the laser that put it into
the laboratory
prior to that I mean you didn't have
light sources that would work so would
it be possible to use optical tweezers
in moving objects in space for example
you mean up here out in space I guess so
I haven't thought about that direction
really but
[Music]
in space I mean I guess then you want to
have if you want to have more than one
spaceship what you really need is to
keep them extremely precise with respect
to each other and data laser of course
plays a very important role and this is
a development I think we will see in the
next 20 years for example in in in
space-based detectors for gravitational
waves and that a nicer place in an
extremely important and the other part
of this year's prize is about high
intensity lasers for short pulses why
did they want to develop such things and
I think there are several reasons I mean
if you saw the curve I did that was the
sort of a plateau over 15 years and as a
physicist you always want to go to the
new frontiers you want to push the
policy intensity you want to go to
higher and higher intensity where you
really start to not only talk to the
molecule or atom but really to seriously
influence it and this is something that
really started with the invention of the
CPA technique because then you get
pulses or sufficiently high intensity so
that when interacting with atoms and
molecules it was no longer a small
perturbation but it was a drastic change
of the electron shell of the atom and
this then led to strong field physics
and out to second metrology in physics
at the second science so that was an
important
application rather unexpected I would
say I mean around 1985 there was no no
clear understanding of what would happen
if you expose atoms to such strong
fields you can take a movie of what's
happening in the economy yes yes you can
start to take movies of the electron
motion in the molecule or atom and this
was of course science fiction for for a
long time the curve in the development
of intensity for lasers and it kind of
never stopped
how intense can those laser beams be I
don't I don't I don't see a showstopper
right now I mean the there will be new
materials that will mean new ideas how
you can the basic science theorem is
understandable
and then it's the question of the scale
and how much you can copy you can do
things and so on and so I don't I don't
see that there is a this will go on and
that's what I indicated with the dashed
line I means going on before for one
more decade all those instruments of the
tweezers a very small instrument that's
more like a microscope the CPA based
laser sight as I didn't I didn't have
time to show it here but it can either
be very very compact instrument that you
use for eye surgery which is something
that fits easily into a I mean it's not
it's not more bigger than when you go to
the dentist for example I mean it's the
same size of instruments when you come
to laser plus my acceleration then we're
talking about really big lasers I mean
filling up a big laboratory but that's
that's the beauty of this technique is
that it's scalable it's scalable you can
scale it down if you want to have high
rep rate you want to have ultra precise
interaction with something for example
the eye or you want to drill though
you're going to make Stan's and so on or
you can emphasize really the high
intensity frontier
and if you interact the really highest
intensity policies with matter then of
course you're creating extreme
conditions that doesn't really exist on
earth naturally but for example may
exist in in in astrophysics in the
interior of planets and so on so that's
that's direction I would call laboratory
astrophysics but still with their other
high rep right I mean one Hertz is quite
you know it's quite often when you have
this is not only the third woman in
physics Nobel Prize history but also she
was a PhD student when she made this
great invention you have any good advice
for PhD students today how to become
important dishes the work I think if you
repeat is if you're a potential PhD
student you should look for something
that really interests you you should
look for groups that are very good in
that particular area that interests you
and then try to start to get the PhD
position in one of these groups I think
if you start with something that you
doesn't really inspire you I don't think
that's that's not right
then you're on the wrong wrong track you
should choose the topic first then look
for people that are doing this and try
to select the best it's not easy
admittedly but
thank you very much okay